Schon seit anfang juni ist der mars rover opportunity der nasa sturm werden darüber berichtet ein gewaltiger staubsturm war bei den roten planeten
geprägt und hatte den rover damit daran gehindert seine batterien wieder aufzuladen
und daran hat sich nichts geändert die nasa ist besorgt und hat jetzt einen plan aufgestellt wie es mit ihrem mars-rover
weitergehen wie kritisch die lage möglich ist jetzt bei klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Der standort ist klar viel mehr aber auch nicht der mars rover opportunity
verharrt auf dem roten planeten an einer stelle namen space marines valley
doch er meldet sich nicht zurück und das schon seit dem 10 juni
ja jetzt versucht es das nasa forschungsteam offensichtlich mit allen mitteln so heißt es dass jeden morgen passende aufwacht lieder gespielt werden wie etwa
here comes the sun
von den beatles denn wie der zustand des rovers hat wirklich ist bleibt weiter unter und der song wird quasi als signal
genutzt um dann eine antwort vom nova zu bekommen doch das forschungsteam hofft weiter darauf dass sich der oper wegen des fehlenden
sonnenlicht selbst ausgeschaltet hat die nasa selbst bezeichnet die lage als kritisch dennoch sei man vorsichtig optimistisch schließlich
habe opportunity schon viele kritische situationen und
herausforderungen gemeistert und das waren in seinen 14 jahren auf dem mars so einige dennoch steht auch fest der rover hat bereits jetzt
60 mal länger als eigentlich geplant auf dem roten planeten ausgehalten denn ursprünglich war seine mission auf 90 tage ausgelegt seine
garantie frist ist also schon längst verstrichen sein zwillings rover spirit war mit ihm im jahr
2004 auf dem mars gelandet und hatte ebenfalls den eigentlichen plan weit übertroffen er hatte 20 mal länger auf dem mars
ausgehalten als ursprünglich vorgesehen dazu einer der beteiligten nasa projektmanager john
callas wir hoffen dass unser bei
herrlicher rover seine füße noch einmal aus dem feuer ziehen kann wenn er es schafft werden wir da sein und ihn hören und das dürfte
eigentlich nicht mehr also lange dauern falls die funkstille
tatsächlich an dem staubsturm liegt denn der hat nachgelassen und der dunst um opportunity
lichtet sich so langsam lehrplan der nasa jedenfalls ist ausgetüftelt erst wenn das so genannte travel
1,5 fällt werden die experten wieder mit einer aktiven
kontaktaufnahme staaten das travel ist eine einheit mit der sich die anzahl der staubpartikel in der marsatmosphäre
messen lässt das sogenannte deep space network der nasa soll dann kommandos zum mars schicken und hören was dabei herumkommt wenn
opportunity antwortet soll laut des zwei stufen plans sein status ermittelt werden und der rover dann
schnellstmöglich wieder online gebracht werden es gibt aber auch noch ein zweites mögliches szenario
wie sieht es für opportunity
alles andere als gut aus denn die nasa kann nicht
ausschließen dass die empfindlichen geräte des rovers durch die massive kälte auf dem mars gestört worden sind und die funk stelle stelle
daher rührt dazu colours wenn wir nach 45 tagen keine reaktion des rovers bekommen wird das team gezwungen sei
davon auszugehen dass der rover sich nicht mehr erholen wird wir werden in diesem fall aber mehrere monate lang weiter
passiv nach opportunity lauschen
selbst dann bei einer solchen passiven suche nach signalen gibt es nach angaben der nasa aber noch hoffnung der grund ein phänomen das man
2004 sowohl bei spirit als auch bei opportunity
beobachtet hatte damals waren die energie level der rover über nacht um mehrere prozent
angestiegen und das obwohl sie nachts hätten eigentlich ab fallen sollen doch das rätsel konnte
gelüftet werden eine staub hose also vom wind aufgewirbelte staub hatte die
solarpaneele gesäubert genau das könnte natürlich auch im besten fall jetzt wieder passiert falls
opportunity dagegen für immer verstummt sein sollte kann die nasa sicher noch mit goya city trösten denn dieser rover ist nicht
von sonnenenergie abhängig zudem soll die ende november ein weiterer länder auf dem mars ankommen sein name inside
seine mission das innere des mars erforschen und jetzt clixoom wird werbefrei keine triumph mehr mit eurer hilfe
immer wenn wir
entsprechend viele kanal mitglieder gewonnen haben schalten wir die werbung vor jeweils einem video im monat ab bald ist es beim ersten video soweit werdet
also mit liegt hier unter dem video drauf kriegen
und bekommt noch exklusive extra videos exklusive live streams wie am kommenden dienstag und noch ein paar weitere
wir legen ein riesen dank an all diejenigen die schon dabei sind das ist wirklich absolut
fantastisch ja es werden immer mehr und wenn ihr immer
garantiert über aktuelle videos informiert werden wollt dann hättet mich übrigens bei whatsapp dann bekommt er
den link zum video vor allen anderen von mir persönlich auf euer handy einfach hier draufklicken
und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch dort blicken 1000 raketen zum mars bis dann
bleibt dran